Some alternative cancer practitioners say that cancer is very smart and you should alter
your approach, perhaps changing the way you take care of neutrocynicals.
I think also to write, also changes up application of frequencies for similar reasons, thoughts
on doing this.
Well, certainly if a person's cancer is continuing to grow, we always want to look at adding
different frequencies.
So I don't tend to think we need to change the true right frequencies that often are in
the case of how I program the rights for people, not that I'm special, but most people
use the her true right, like an hour a day at maximum.
So we're using it all like long.
So I put so many different frequencies in your night.
Now, I am not opposed at all to say, hey, I'm totally willing to, if you want me to tweak
up your programming, I would gladly do that for you.
Now I will almost always do that if a person is getting worse or something's metastasized
and I tested it comes out that there will be tweak in their program.
So you just, you know, send in a cheek swab with that request.
That's why we put that, that's why I put that request on the cheek swab form.
You want me to specifically check for frequency changes.
And this is why we've said over and over about to neutral suiticles to sometimes it can be good
to do what's called, that's not a complete change of your neutral suiticles, but, but pulsing
your neutral suiticles.
So you might go off for a week, just kind of clean up your body, clean up, go off for a week.
That can be the case with a rash too.
You can be developed by sensitivity to actually what are your supplements, that's a possibility.
So, you think about, you know, pulsing them instead of pulsing them all off for a week, pulse
off one at a time for a week, see if there's any change in the rash, maybe that's, maybe
that's a possibility what's going on too.